quanto detto di ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo incredibile video su questa
cosa è una cosa che non ho mai fatto
quindi su una roba nuova che è la
reaction ahimè me che hanno fatto su di
me perché effettivamente ci sono messe
di vettimo reddito che oggi reagisco a
praticamente tutti i me me che sono
stati fatti su di me quindi cominciamo
vediamo che cosa che cosa è uscito forma
paura incredibile ma va beh vedo vedo
che abbiamo rope c'è insomma originali
non vedo niente di troppo strano in
tutto questo se non andiamo con calma
peter griffin che gioca a skyrim con una
grafica elevatissima effettivamente
quando agli amici di lorenzo salgono in
macchina per la prima volta con lui
neopatentato jam pizzi pronto ora
nessuno ma proprio nessuno passante che
incontra famiglie in macchina timing del
general se puoi metterlo su basa anche
sulla torta mi fa ridere dunque
copyright sulla canzone disconnect dei
peg corners esiste silence proprio le
venti autori parigi e poi ragazzi questa
cosa non lo sapete ma ve la spiego
praticamente una volta io mettevo disco
ne chiede che la mia canzone preferita
andato a cercarla perchè è bellissima e
non era copyright a tali integri la
usavo poi certo punto hanno deciso di
coprire i tar l'ha proprio o più una
trave di ferro in testa mi han dato e
minini niente altrove per peccato perché
bene avanti tanti soldi per la se allora
comunque ball mar miglior
emerge senza ombra di dubbio perché le
sue sono over the top per la serie
quando ci c'è poi viceparroco clip
ciccio merino poi c'è chi ciò ti devi
impegnare e se ti dicessi che può essere
divertente senza urlare triggers
effettivamente questa roba l'ho capita
solo nel 2016 sono di tre anni ma vado a
ragazzi allora non sono io l'unica
persona malata che quando stava a scuola
si scriveva sulla calcolatrice delle
cagate mostruose
vabbè vabbè forse l'avevo fatta non sono
sicuro ma potrei averlo fatto apposta
nessuno assolutamente nessuno
portafoglio di famiglia e sparisce qua
ci stavo in esilio again
però non si può mettere che stanno
finisce come la mia vecchia vetro con
copyright quando favi già iniziano a
live di loket quando inizi a giocare
quando subisce gol quando prende 7 mila
sono il male protettivi porco del
demonio faccio una crossbar challenge
dopo l'altra io aveva bensì allora c'è
un attimo didier avevo le pellicole come
mamma per favore possiamo comprare keanu
reeves mamma abbiamo già keanu reeves a
casa che hanno riso a casa sono partiti
neve ricordo mi sono spaccato ginocchio
geniale quando mani il tuo pp alla tua
cresce non ti risponde ma poi dopo dieci
minuti lei ti manda al suo a quando ti
addormenti sul divano e ti risvegli sul
letto ma poi ti ricordi gli dà solo
quando vuoi portare noi contenuti ma la
gente continua chiara tf che mai questa
questa realtà effettiva e beni che
comunque la faccia è quella e quella ai
banner ciccio ciccio fa un altro account
hanno bannato ciccio perché clamav agli
avversari giuro che clio
e come ultimo cyberpunk 2077 se io
avessi il mirino così istruzioni per
casa dunque sarebbe fighissimo ma
comunque ragazzi questo era il la
reaction ahimè mi schiera di scordare ci
si diverte si parla si fanno le cose
potete anche consigliarmi giochi in
giochi supremi perché in base ai giochi
che mi consigliate voi poi gli farò sul
pianale e quando scelgo il gioco
consigliato da qualcuno
dico grazie a tappone è vincente
nell'esperienza sul disco quando vi con
sé quando c'è questo gioco oltre che
essere nominati del video quindi date il
vostro contributo alla community disco
migliori tanto ci andiamo ragazzi al
prossimo video vis chiede al canale l'ha
subito il commento un bacino e quasi
sempre al vino bella ragazza
[Musica]